devonna to me was always a threesome and
then when kurt said let's bring pat into
nirvana were you shocked were you like
no no no it's the three of us
was it weird for you to become a
foreigner no well you know
uh nirvana at one point had
another guitarist like in 1989 or 1990
this dude named jason everman was in the
band for a bit and then they went back
to being a three-piece so it didn't seem
weird to me
um we had just made this record and
kurt's like i feel like we need another
guitar player to fill out some of the
guitar parts
and the craziest thing was that you know
pat comes from
pat's from los angeles and was in this
legendary punk rock band called the
germs that we all grew up listening to
like we worshiped the germs and
you know we were talking about other
guitar players kurt comes back from los
angeles he's like i found our second
guitar player like who he said
pat smear from the germs and i was just
like honestly my first reaction was like
that guy's still alive really like
if you only knew like what the germs did
and what they were like
and then he walks in he's pat smear like
hey and
i mean for the last year of the band it
was like it made the band
a lot more fun to be in having pat in
the band was it weird for you
i mean to go into a band that's tight
already and then have to join them
like later in the game i would think
it's kind of
it's kind of cool but it also kind of
sucks because you got to get up to speed
with these guys
it was only weird immediately and then
it got
cool real fast and uh what was weird
your first gig was snl yeah right out of
the game on the stage
was kurt that kind of guy like he's like
hey pat just come on snl with us
yeah he just called me up and said you
want to be in my band
i'm like okay i've met him
i don't know once or twice i didn't know
him at all i knew courtney
so uh i guess she gave me an endorsement
so you didn't have to audition i mean
like
what happens like so for the first gig
yeah i know he's pat smear but jesus
christ we gotta at least see
i guess you're right i mean it would be
insulting i asked the same question
like what if they don't like me and he
said right
i'd be all paranoid i mean to be honest
when pat joined the band he was the best
musician
in nirvana you know so it's not like he
wasn't joining like the philharmonic
orchestra it was like
you know he was already over qualified
why do you say that though i mean you're
i would say am i wrong you're wrong
i am not wrong dave are you not a great
musician i mean i do not see
yourself the story you told me once pat
about you guys
you and kurt walking by dave playing
kurt's left-handed guitar
yeah dave we're backstage at a gig once
and
dave's noodling around in guitar and me
and kurt walked by and we stared him for
a minute and we go in the next room and
we started laughing we're like oh my god
he's better than
both of us
you